Donald Trump has issued a stark warning
to Iran threatening to hit dozens of
targets inside the Islamic Republic if
it retaliates for the targeted killing
of top commander Qasem Soleimani the US
president fired off a series of tweets
part of which said Iran is talking very
boldly about targeting certain USA asset
assets as revenge for our ridding the
world of their terrorist leader let this
serve as a warning that if Iran strikes
any Americans or American assets we've
targeted 52 Iranian sites and those
targets and Iran itself will be hit very
fast and very hard the USA wants no more
threats
let's live Kosta gave Elizondo now in
Washington DC hi there Gabe so President
Trump releasing this series of tweets
warning Iran about any sort of response
what else has he been saying yeah this
appears to be a president that is
consumed at every hour about what Iran
might be doing next and how do we know
that from his Twitter feed it was just a
little after midnight here in Washington
time that Trump set out even more
threats towards Iran this just came out
in the last hour too it said and I'm
gonna read part of it says the United
States just spent two trillion dollars
on military equipment we are the biggest
and by far the best in the world if Iran
attacks an American base or any American
we will be sending some of that brand
new beautiful equipment their way and
without hesitation again that a tweet
from the president a little after
midnight and he's really drawing quite
frankly a dangerous red line there
basically escalating the situation even
more so basically in that tweet
guaranteeing that he will call he will
retaliate against Iran should Iran
strike any US interests here this is a
little bit surprising because we've been
hearing all day on Saturday from
administration officials who are saying
they were trying to de-escalate the
situation including Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo who said that was the main
priority was to de-escalate meanwhile
you have these series of tweets
the president doing exactly the opposite
and in some of his earlier tweets on
Saturday where he mentioned over 50
targets that the US had on their list he
said some of them were important
cultural sites to the to Iran Iran has
more than 20 UNESCO World Heritage Sites
in the country of Iran and targeting
those militarily would be a war crime
nevertheless that is what the president
tweeted at least and gave there's been
some fascinating content in The New York
Times article reporting that the
Pentagon officials were quote stunned
when Trump chose the most extreme option
of killing soon avani when there were
other choices given to the president
yeah some administration officials
anonymously are talking to the New York
Times and they're reporting that the
Pentagon gave Trump what's called a menu
of options in response to the attack on
the US Embassy in Baghdad Trump asked
for a menu of options military options
that that could be undertaken and on
those options the Pentagon said that
they could strike Iran Iran boats or
ships there could strike Iran military
missile launching places they could
strike some militia and also said that
they could strike directly at sulemani
now when Trump said that is the option
he wanted to go with that apparently
shocked the Pentagon they were not
expecting that they scrambled to get
plans in place and it was Thursday night
according to this report that Trump
ultimately told the Pentagon to
assassinate sulemani and on Friday
that's exactly what happened
administration officials are telling
they're saying that it was in in many
ways an impulsive decision by Trump or
that's how it's being characterized by
some at least within the administration
that has spoken of the times
Gabe Elizondo there with the very latest
from the US and from Washington DC Gabe
thank you